in this video i'm going to talk to you
about incentives how to get people to do
the things you want and if you don't
know what the definition of power is by
the way the definition of power is how
to influence events or people all right
so the ability to direct or influence
events or people that is the definition
of power and so most people hopefully if
you're watching this you want to become
more powerful and the thing is that word
makes you feel queasy on the inside it's
because you have a very poor definition
of power power is neither good nor bad
what you do with it can be good or bad
right it's just it is just raw potential
so in this video and if you don't know
who i am by the way my name is alex
ramose on acquisition.com it's a
portfolio of companies over 100 million
dollars a year and i have nothing to
sell you and i make these videos because
a lot of people are broke and i don't
want you to be one of them all right i
also have a lot of fun doing this and so
that is why i make them all right like i
said nothing to sell you except
hopefully just these lovely watch times
on these vids and the skills that come
with it that were relatively hard earned
okay so you want people to do stuff
right there's the component of
persuasion in getting them to believe
that it is in their best interest that
is fundamentally what leadership is to
get someone to believe that doing the
thing that you want them to do is really
just get them to want to do that right
that is what it is and so a lot of
leadership is power which and a lot of
power if you sign the definition is
selling but today i'm not talking about
selling i'm talking about incentives
right so this is like kind of the the
brass tack side there's the persuasion
the soft side which is still very
important the psychology side the other
side is kind of the behavioral side and
so this is adapted from a conversation
that i had with my closest friend dr
trevor cashy and we were talking about
behavior and getting humans to comply
and so what i want to talk to you about
is the ways to do that and so a big part
of that if my my little my little doodad
will start working that's what she said
um here we go and we're gonna make a
little boxy do boxy do
fantastic boxy do completed okay so it's
not a perfect box deal with it you've
got pluses
and you've got minuses and you can add
them or you could subtract them what
this means is that we have a combination
of both punishment and we have reward
stuff that people don't want and stuff
that people do want all right so for
example and i'm going to give a
simplistic reasoning to get someone to
do something so we'll use a simple one
which is how do you get your kid to
clean their room this is a simple
example that you can extrapolate to
whatever it is that you want someone
else to do you can add a good thing i
can give you a cookie that is something
that i can do i can if you do the chore
i will give you a cookie simple you do
the thing you get the reward awesome the
next thing that we could do is we could
subtract a negative you get no cookies
all right so they don't get to have
dessert anymore which would be
impossible because you can never skip
dessert right
like not in this family right and so we
could subtract something that they do
have that they like right so if you
don't do your chores i will remove video
games or you don't get to eat dessert
makes sense so those are two things that
we can do with a positive or a reward on
the reverse of this is that we can add a
negative so we can say i will spank your
ass i'm going to add a negative i'm
going to spank your ass if you don't if
you don't do your chores oh no that
sucks right but i'm going to add
something that wasn't currently in your
life that you will not like all right as
we add a negative the fourth thing that
we can do and i'll get to how you can
think through these in a second we can
subtract a negative okay so i can uh i
plan on speaking every day and i i can
remove spanking or let's say there's
something that you uh that you don't
like doing which might be like you're
expected to do the dishes right you
don't have to do the dishes or let's say
you don't like it you know you don't
like riding the bus right so you're only
riding the bus i'll drive you to school
that's kind of like taking away native
and adding a positive ah right and so we
can do no dishes which would be
subtracting a negative think about these
in this way these are things that people
want to avoid and these are people
things that they want here's what's kind
of interesting about all of this stuff
incentives drive behavior there's
tremendous amount of documentation on
that hopefully you're not going to fight
that point with me all right but here's
what's interesting when you create
punishments for people people do
anything to avoid the punishment which
may not mean doing the thing that you
want them to do so for example if your
child sneaks out at night and then you
punish them for sneaking out the
incentive is not necessarily stop
sneaking out the incentives to stop
getting caught right it encourages
criminal behavior it encourages people
to find new and ingenuitive ways to do
the thing they want to do which is their
incentive their plus side and figure out
a ways to avoid the downside here's what
is kind of interesting about this is
that with punishments in general
you get people to avoid the behavior but
you don't get them necessarily to do
what you want them to do so if you want
someone to do something it's much easier
to incentivize that if you do the thing
right you get this
right because incentives direct behavior
punishments force people to avoid
anything that will give them the
punishment it's subtle but hopefully
you're picking up what i'm putting down
the reason this i think is very
interesting is that when you look at so
jim collins uh wrote a lot of the best
management books that are out there and
what's interesting if you if you follow
his career it seems like he's he went
from super super quantitative to more
qualitative now he still did
quantitative to arrive at his
qualitative decisions but he talks about
how leadership is such an important part
of building great businesses and we know
that great people build great companies
okay and so we as entrepreneurs must be
leaders and good people so that we can
attract good people so we can build good
companies now a big part of that is
figuring out how to get people to do
stuff and so based on the research that
he had that he had presented which i
thought was really fascinating is that
over time if you have negative
reinforcement performance degrades right
it's always critical feedback always
critical feedback always negative only
only talk to somebody when they do
something wrong on the flip side if you
have positive feedback by large majority
of the time performance improves isn't
that interesting
and so i saw that through this lens
which is we can we can direct people's
behavior far more effectively with
positive incentives than we do with
negative stuff which has huge
implications for like the jail system
and the punitive system and all that
stuff is like people just find ways to
avoid punishment they don't necessarily
do what people want them to do because
it's much because punishment it just
people can the the the activity sprays
in any direction that's just away from
the thing whereas incentives directs it
towards what you want all right and so
we think about this this within the
context of managing people and getting
to do the things that we want them to do
then it makes more sense for us to add
to to think about an activity rather
than a single outcome into as many many
many many incremental steps as we
possibly can and then incentivize those
many steps and the incentives don't
necessarily need to be monetary in fact
most times they don't need to be
monetary they need to be things that
people can perceive as positive outcomes
which many times is just status and
feedback which is just great job awesome
stuff you did that thing yesterday and
it was great you just reinforce the
things that they are doing that are good
and we reinforce and then now that
they've realized i did this one thing
not anything to avoid something but i
did this one thing and i got this cookie
well i want to do that one thing again
and then get another cookie right and we
reinforce behavior and so
i like this this process of thinking and
trevor and i talk about this a lot
because it gets around the hullabaloo of
trying to figure out what's going on
inside of people's heads right and what
we have instead are
circumstances and the outcomes right and
then we have our incentives and all of
these things we can measure we can say i
saw that this person we were in this
circumstance which we measure we
inserted uh this incentive and then they
did this outcome yes or no right whether
they felt
inspired or whether they psychologically
loved we don't know and we never will
know because not everyone even knows how
they're feeling and whether they answer
questions is not necessarily even true
we have no idea but if we can just
measure the conditions then we can start
directing behavior in the right ways and
so i thought this was a fascinating
topic
for getting others and this applies to
spouses how do you get your spouse to do
the stuff that you want them to do it
certainly doesn't come from nagging them
all the time all they're going to do is
try to avoid being nagged
interesting right and so this gives you
four boxes to look at the the these two
you can't really see them but anyways
this one this box over here this guy and
this guy those are things that you can't
really direct people's behavior as much
whereas this guy and this guy you can
direct people's behavior to the singular
outcome that you're looking for and you
continuously reinforce those behaviors
such that they start doing them without
even thinking about it because it has
been so reinforced right and so instead
of trying to think how do i how do i
have an amazing marriage it's how can i
condition this person to stay married to
me kind of interesting little flip for
you so anyways mosey nation this is the
kind of stuff that i do
geek out on and i think it's really
interesting um i hope you enjoyed it as
much as i enjoyed making this for you
this is how you get people to do [ __ ]
you can think about it in the terms of
soft side in terms of persuasion but you
can also think about in terms of the
hard side of what are the the
reinforcements that we're going to use
either positive or negative and we're
going to add positives we're going to
remove positives we're going to add
negatives we're going to remove
negatives so that we can accomplish what
we want together so lots of buzzy nation
let me know if you like the stuff in the
comments and keeping awesome i'll see
you guys next video bye